[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
mike lowe kind enough to join us mlb
network analyst he won two world series
titles and he was the 07 world series
mvp mike congrats that was great tv last
night and the fact that you followed up
and called xander bogarts and got even
more information but can you try to
capsulize what what happened on that
play
that we wouldn't have seen as just
baseball fans
well thank you dan i appreciate the the
kind words um you know it's it's always
a benefit when
the head coach uh the manager is one of
your best friends so i actually called
alex cora you know to congratulate him
and i said
you know we're going to do a breakdown
cliff and i and what we noticed xander
keeps looking to third and you know
fenway is a very different type park you
know center field is much shallower the
ball caroms off that wall so much harder
than normal parks
so i said is he looking at devers
because sometimes you know when i was
playing third
you'd kind of point you know because you
don't hear 444 you don't you know you
got to be looking and i said or is he
looking at phil nevin and he goes well
xander's right next to me i'll put you
on speaker so i was like oh wow how
great is this so i asked him he's like
i'm looking at at nevin and i found that
to be so unique because
you know guys run through stop signs all
the time so so to look at
what the third base coach was doing i
thought was really special because
his other thing is right before he's
pointing at christian arroyo to stay on
second base
as the as the second cut guy because if
he's holding judge
they want to keep the double play in
order or have a play at second if
stanton goes for the double so there
were so many components to that that i
was like man this is fascinating we
gotta you know kind of bring maybe the
fan into it and the fact you know it's a
playoff game so we have so many
different camera angles when they show
the one from above where it really shows
him looking at judge touched second
going a third and then really staring at
nevin to the point where he's still
looking at him and kiki's balls in the
air so that was really cool for me and
and you know kk's ball was a good short
hop you know you don't want to get that
in between hop he put his feet perfectly
he saw that stanton wasn't going they
were waving judge
the transition was perfect and it was a
huge part of the game too you know you
he's safe at home and his three to two
one out runner on second you know i
think all the momentum that the red sox
had really would have changed there and
he's not known as a great fielder had
the big home run as well but once again
to put this in layman's terms what mike
was talking about and how fascinating it
was
bogart's is is going to get the relay
he's looking at the third base coach and
the ball is in the air and he's looking
at phil nevin and then looks back
presence of mind scoop it off the bounce
and then turn and throw because he knows
that he's going home i i um
no i thought it was wonderful i i
thought it was great inside baseball and
uh something that i never would have
thought of because i think everybody
thought
should he have sent him you know the
yankees are very aggressive phil nevin's
an aggressive third base coach and he
sends aaron judge and you even said he's
got plus speed uh what was it the wrong
move though if you if you look at the
situation
we know what the end result is mike was
it was it wrong on phil nevin to send
him in that situation i don't think so
and and my main reason for saying that
is
there weren't there would there weren't
no outs so i don't want the first out
being at home plate and even though your
cleanup hitters you know the next guy up
joey gallo is hitting a buck 60 for you
you know he's a big strikeout guy not to
say well look i told you so he ends up
popping to short left field you know to
so i i don't know if the yankees have
the confidence in the in gallow torres
and the guys that follow him after that
so i gotta push the button a little and
going back to your point and the way
judge gets on
is kind of a chopper to xander bogart
said he beats out so that that's kind of
been the
analytics knock on xander bogart he
doesn't have those great numbers on
defensive run save but that play
never comes up in the analytics and it's
literally he's saving a run and it'll
never come out it'll come out as a he
handled a good relay and made a good
throw which a lot of shortstops can do
but in that situation
i don't think a lot of shortstops take
into account everything
that went on in that play you can watch
mike lowell in
major league baseball network the
two-time world series champ he was the
mvp of the 2007 world series mvp and you
can watch mlb central at 11 a.m eastern
plus mlb network will exclusively air
game two between the white sox and the
astros that'll be tomorrow afternoon
uh the dodgers last night it didn't seem
fair that either one of these teams was
going to lose um what do you take away
from that game uh if you're dave roberts
and the dodgers and you know
subsequently the giants watching what
happened last night
well i think it sets up for a great
rivalry you know dodgers giants for you
know the nlds
i think it would have been a crying
shame that a team that wins 106 games
during the regular season you know goes
home after one not that i was rooting
for my just for the
for the
integrity of playing 162. you know and
that's
i'm more of the advocate of the tv
must-see elimination game it's fantastic
you know i was glued to the tv with
yankees red sox i was glued last night
um i just it hurts me to think that you
put in six months of work and you play
10 times the games that a football team
does and it comes down to one i don't
like that i i like i would much prefer a
two out of three but
what i did take away from that dan is
the dodgers bullpen is pretty good yeah
because max sures are you know for me
the aces
what really makes an ace is when
they don't have their good stuff do they
still grind it out you know and max
scherzer was a little off and he still
grinds out one run just over you know
five and a third he lays it out to the
bullpen and that combination joe kelly's
been on fire kelly janssen looks great
again trying was fantastic you know they
got a lot of arms that
come post season you do have you play
two games in an off day you play another
two games in an off day so you you can
get rest in
the same guy can you know in a five game
series he can throw four games in a
seven game series he can throw five
games so
i i think dave roberts has to be really
happy with his options that he can go to
after his starters they're so loaded
anyways i mean the depth really shows
with that team
yeah and i wonder if if you polled a
baseball fan who didn't have a rooting
interest what's the match up you want
dodgers astros make the most sense
from a talent standpoint
i think the astros are super underrated
you know i
the giants i think
kind of surpassed all expectations i
mean most people i think predicted
probably third in their own division
so the fact that they won so many games
is is pretty incredible you know i give
gabe kepler a lot of credit yeah but the
dodgers are so deep and i think you run
through that astros lineup and
you know you say well they got out two
of them bregman and correa and brantley
and their best hitters kyle tucker you
know he's kind of one of these under the
radar guys who's gonna hit seventh in
the lineup so they're they're real deep
um their starting staff is much better
than people think
so i i think there are a lot of good
teams left it makes for a pretty potent
post season for you know the fans to
kind of get engaged with what did you
win winning the mvp in 2007
uh two cars
it was pretty good and a nice little
bumper
yeah i don't know i think it was the
first time chevy they were kind of going
through the hybrid so they gave me a
hybrid tahoe and a hybrid uh i think
chevy malibu
so where are they
uh i kept the tahoe now i mean it's been
a few years dan so i kept the tahoe used
that one for a few years
uh the malibu i actually one of my good
friend's daughter was going to school so
we kind of worked out a nice little deal
for her there so i can't say i drove the
mallet
what's your favorite story with those
red sox that you're allowed to tell
allowed to tell yeah because you were
under the radar like you didn't make
headlines you just went out there and
played every day
you know you you were a baseball player
you had personalities on there
we did you know and i think the the best
i guess story that i could tell is
when we got into each city
you know the coaching staff and the
media that belong with the team that
travel with the team going one bus and
the players are all on the second bus
and you're all going to the hotel
and david ortiz always gets on the mic
and first of all he starts asking the
bus driver
bus driver
do you know who we are you know he
starts asking and you know the buster
you know you get very different person
some guys don't want to talk like yeah
poppy i know who you are and he goes you
know we got a guy on our team that
played with bay ruth
in wakefield so then they start going
back and forth and wakes in the back
and he's like
why don't you go see a dentist you got
some gap near so it was a really good
back and forth probably a little bit uh
not very politically correct in these
days but uh those stories
those stories are good you know that's
that's the camaraderie that i think
for me as a former player i love
covering the game and baseball but those
are the times you miss you know i don't
think people miss the travel it's kind
of like the off the field stuff and you
know the things you did together as a
team did you cowboy up did you do shots
before uh postseason games i was not
part of cowboy up although kevin millar
was my teammate with with the marlins
for a number of years um i'm not gonna
say i've never taken a shot before a
game
um
you know sometimes when you're in a big
slump dance you go to some extreme
measure you know you got to do it you
know maybe a bp little
little hit was not out of the question
but uh
uh
those were those were good times you
know i i really felt like in my career
i went from you know the attendance you
know the lowest attendance with the
marlins when you know we were and we're
a pretty good team and we're playing in
front of 6 000 fans especially we're
making a little bit of a run
to boston where you know every game that
i played for five years in fenway was a
sellout you know it's a pretty cool uh
that's a pretty cool experience what's
the strangest thing you ever heard when
you're playing in front of
no crowd no audience with uh the marlins
oh cell phones for me i one was actually
the craziest one was right after the
hurricanes uh i think it was katrina
that went through florida and you know
kind of canceled our games we had to
play the expos
in chicago
in kaminsky whatever it's called now i
don't know they changed so imagine that
the expos they don't draw well the
marlins that don't draw well playing the
game in chicago i think we drew like 800
fans so there i do remember a cell phone
went off he's like yeah i grabbed great
seats
yeah lowell's right there he's probably
not going to hit much today and i'm like
i can hear you that's not fair you know
so yeah
you uh it's much better 40 000 is much
better because everything's just a buzz
you don't really hear when they're
criticizing you so i prefer that before
i say goodbye uh vegas still has the
dodgers the favorites to win it all
you agree
yeah uh i do i mean uh i love to play
blackjack but i'm not betting on
baseball you know for
whatever reason uh they're just so deep
you know i look at their lineup and they
miss max muncie and you look at the
lineup they put out there like wow
that's a pretty deep lineup for the
postseason so
uh i give them a lot of credit a lot of
people were like oh they're just
stacking guys but you know the ownership
is willing to pay the dollars for you
know and there are a lot of teams that
are in markets that can do the same
thing and
you know the dodgers find a way if you
told me they were going to pick up
scherzer and turner at the deadline i'd
say you're crazy so they
they go out and do it they want to win
and they're stacking their team and i
don't have a problem with a team that's
willing to spend to make their team as
good as possible mike it's great to talk
to you again uh please pass it on to
cliff that you guys did a wonderful job
that was that was great tv last night
and uh we'll be watching during the post
season
i will thank you dan appreciate it
that's uh michael the major league
baseball network analyst and won the
world series twice
and the mvp in uh 07.